Hey, Stefan, good afternoon.
Hey, sorry, I was finishing a call with Ben.
No problem, completely understandable. It looks like Ashish is also tied up. I have just texted him right now. Would you like to stay on the call or would you like me to get it rescheduled for you, whatever that works best?
No worries.
Honestly, I don't think there's too much to talk about. Arnie has been given a couple things. He's been working on them diligently and, you know, nothing's changed since last month. We give him stuff, he gets it done, we move forward.
Lights.
Yeah.
Glad, glad. So are you overall satisfied with the level of support which you are getting? Is reaching up to your expectations?
Yes.
Yes, we are.
Awesome, awesome. Glad to hear that. While you are there, Stephen, just wanted to confirm, have you registered for the Build It or Ben, has he registered for the Build It event?
I believe you guys were a part of, not yet, there hasn't been the, we haven't started sending out the emails because we are still finalizing the agenda. We just wanted to make sure as you have been a part of the earlier events. So let me quickly bring it up on the screen what the event is all about.
Have we received?
Okay.
Haight.
Oh, hey, Ashish, thanks for joining in.
Morning, Stephen, how are you?
Great. Good morning.
Yep.
While you were away, Stephen and I were chit chatting about Arnie. So just to give you a heads up, Ashish, he's taking care of the things effectively. I was going to utilize the time to share some information regarding our Build It event. You don't trust me.
I want to hear this from Stephen.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm just kidding, just kidding.
No, I was just saying I was, yeah, Arnie's Arnie's been doing everything we've been giving him, so yeah.
You.
Mhm.
Night, night.
Thank you so much, ****.
And you have already got it on a recorded line, Ashish.
Mmh.
OK, yeah, 30 people go.
Thanks. But that's definitely helpful, Stephen. So the Build It event is one of our most awaited event for the year where it's hosted by us. This is our 8th event in the series. We were able to take our partners to NASA Space Center. Before that, it was MetLife Stadium. We have booked Statue of Liberty.
So this time it's happening in the month of August, August 3rd to 5th. Let me bring it up on the screen so that it will give you more clarity. I hope it will be visible.
Okay, yeah, I see it.
Yep, that's so if I talk about the speaker, so we have a lineup of speakers available. We will have John C. Maxwell, Dan Sullivan will be coming in all together. There will be 70 plus channel influencers with 550 attendees. It's A three-day event altogether, 3rd, 4th, 5th, that's happening in.
Hyatt Regency, New Jersey City. If I talk about the focus will be more on the AI services, the kind of implementations which we have already done in our industry. So we have created customized bots who can take care of the dispatching, who can work as an L1 agent. So that's what the focus will be more. Apart from the speaker lineups, you will have different.
session. So that's the venue, Stefan. And then if I talk about the early bird registrations, that will give you one additional ticket. As of now, for the existing partners, the price of the ticket is at 1495. For you specifically, we would love you and the rest of the team members to have you there.
So you have the BOGO offer along with one ticket, you can have one separate ticket. So just to add on to this thing, we have our quarterly AI mastermind that's more like a peer group where we are connecting on a quarterly basis. This is 1 in the year event where most of the MSP channels.
Partner will be available.
Okay.
On the last day, we are able to take our partners to New York Stock Exchange, where there will be a gala party that's specifically limited to 300 partners there with the Great Gatsby team.
Kip.
That's funny.
I believe you will have that dress stitched up.
I have sent the link for your reference. What I'll do once we are done with the call, probably along with the minutes of meeting, I'll send you a separate presentation. It will be just a single pager. If you would like to discuss it with the leadership team, feel free to do so. If you would like me to get on a separate call to provide the required information.
Yeah.
I can go ahead and do that as well.
Yeah, I'll take a look at it. Realistically, it comes down to, you know, we're a pretty small business and we have to try and figure out how this would fit into our regular offerings. Like we would only really have two customers that would really benefit from this type of thing. So I'll definitely take a look at it and see if it's
for sure.
Mmh.
Okay.
something we could utilize. But I was, oh my dog snoring. Might hear her now.
Okay, but I can at least take a look at it within the next week, but kind of just saying it might not apply, but I don't know until I look at it. But thank you for showing it to me.
Okay.
The.
Perfect. Sure, I'll hand it over to Ashish.
Thank you, Sarbjeet. Hey, Stephen. How's everything going?
Hello!
Wonderful. I'm bedridden for another week.
What happened?
Oh, my surgery. I had my surgery 2 weeks ago on my leg. And then I have another surgery on my other leg in four more weeks. So then I'll be completely unable to walk. I have a...
S.
Hoh.
I have a what's called compartment syndrome, where basically anytime I walk or apply pressure to the bottom of my feet, the compartments in the back of my calf, on the back of my leg, there's four compartments. And most people who have this disorder, it only affects two of their compartments, so two of the four. And for me, it's all four in both legs.
It's caused by my trainings in the military. Repetitive, high impact trainings cause this specific.
issue and essentially the fascia, which is like the, I don't even know how to describe fascia. It's like an encasing around the muscle tissue. It grows in a weird way and it holds those compartments where the compartments can't expand when I'm exerting. Because when you like use muscles, they.
Oh.
OK.
swell up and they, you know, kind of like when you're weightlifting, you know, they swell up and they then decrease when you rest. Mine don't have a way to decrease because the fascia has pushed the compartments in a way that they can't expand and release. So they get trapped with high pressure. So once I...
Yes.
start to, you know, exert myself, they get expanded and they stay expanded and they just don't go down. So it causes more and more and more and more pressure till the point that my leg is visibly swollen. And it's an entire leg because it's all four compartments. So this is a new thing I learned about like
Disparish.
because I didn't know that's what I had. And they cut my leg open. They had to cut it for all four compartments. So I have 3 6-inch scars and incision points. And they cut through the fascia. They had to move my nerves over. And then they had to cut the
actual fascia tissue to allow the compartments to release and there was a an actual audible pop like
after they cut it, it was crazy. But I wouldn't know because I was on anesthesia the whole time. But yeah, then they're doing the other leg, but it's been interesting. This should allow me to be able to run again because I haven't been able to run in like 3 years. So
Yeah.
So, do you think about it with Alaska? Would it put an adverse effect on the legs, or would it support it?
This is supposed to allow me to return to like 80% of normal. Before, I could only walk 2 to 4 minutes and my legs would swell up so bad that I'd have to physically sit down right then and there because I couldn't stand on my feet longer than three to four seconds back and forth tapping because of how bad it gets.
They said I won't return back to like regular levels, but I was never going to had I done nothing anyway. So this will put me at like 80% will be 9100. But that's still something.
Yep, at least, yeah, something is better than that.
Yep.
Our well wishes for your speedy recovery system.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, get built in.
But.
But yeah, enough about me.
We, uh...
We're getting some new customers, I believe. We've signed, I think, three in the last month and a half, two months.
We're still growing.
And how's Ben doing? Hoh, how's Ben doing?
Who cares about Ben?
You got new butlers coming in.
Ben's in Vegas every other week. Does he even work here? But Ben is good. Ben has some issues with some flooding in his basement after he just finished getting it remodeled. So he's dealing with some stuff too. But he is good. He is...
Hoh.
It.
Ohh, mommy.
you know, just focusing on trying to grow the business and...
That's great.
Priya.
We're just trying to keep providing good services to people.
Yep, yep, this is why we are here in the business because we are serving our customers the best and we are trying to do it from our core. So yeah, I think we got a line there. And is the hunting season on in Alaska now?
Sure.
So it depends what you're hunting. Hunting season changes, varies on what you're trying to hunt and what time, because there is like trapping season that occurs over the winter, and then there's no trapping during the summer, but then during the summer you have hunting for like bears and moose. So it just depends what you're trying to go for. So the seasons are a little different up here than like other states.
Other states are like from this month to this month, anything. Up here, it's like this and this and this from this season, but this and that and that. Probably because the animals come out differently via different seasons.
Mhm.
But, you know, nine months of winter, you kind of get stuck with a lot of moose.
Yeah.
What, why, why would you hunt a bear? Because I know maybe for skin or fur, but other than that, I don't think any there is any other way of hunting any other use of hunting a bear.
Okay.
I don't know.
But you know what? When you walk into any of our like sport and game shops, like for firearms or bow and arrows or anything like camping supplies, you see all these photos of people who have hunted bears. And they're right there as soon as you walk in. It's like, it's either like an ego thing or they eat the bear. But I can't imagine that bear would taste.
Yes.
Yeah.
good because it seems like it would be chewy.
Hoh.
I don't want to imagine that.
Yeah.
Mm.
Kip.
Okay.
Great. Thank you so much, Stephen. Any other feedback that you have for Arkadi that you want us to work with him?
Nope, we are in the middle of changing our licensing partners from Pax 8 to Ingram. And he's going through all of our customers and doing the partner agreements so that we can get those all moved over. And it's giving him some exposure into all of our customers' Office 365s. And we are.
That's pretty much what he's working on. It's a long and lengthy and boring task, but he's working through it.
OK, yep.
And then he's going to probably have server maintenance when he finishes that.
Absolutely. And thank you so much, Stephen, for approving the holiday request for 25th of May. So, yep, thank you so much. Let me quickly share my screen. We can go through all this data for the past month.
Key.
Please let me know once the screen is visible to you.
I see it.
All right, so welcome to our monthly business review, and the reiteration is April 5th till May 1st. Starting with our agenda items, where we have check-in, highlights of the account, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of the customer, way forward, and then recap.
So we have already covered this slide. I'll skip this one.
Okay.
This is the highlights that we discussed in the previous Connect, where workload you do onboarding several new customers, while also losing two large customers through acquisitions. So, I think Arkadi is helping in terms of getting all the customers on boarded properly. Partner was doing a pretty good job in terms of
Yep.
customer handling, ticket handling, and all other maintenance tasks he does. Thank you so much for sharing the feedback there. Arkadi has grown more confident and collaborated with the team, so thank you so much for sharing this as well. And we were able to finalize the KPIs for Arkadi.
So, we have KB at the next slide. I'll quickly take us through that.
Key.
First we have the action tracker where board reviews will remain the same, no changes there.
Yep.
And here we have the recommended KPIs. So first is attendance, customer satisfaction, and meets deadlines. So this is what we have as a previous connect where Arnie had been on track in all three of the KPIs listed. How about the previous month? Stephen, do you think he's on track or anywhere that you want him to work on?
Nope, he's been on track.
Okay, thank you.
Next, we have this performance analysis. This is with the utilization piece starting April 6th till May 1st, where are these billable had been 9%, his non-billable is 59%. Just for setup use clarity, the non-billable
Beast does not mean that he did not work on anything. It is just how the agreement was designed, whatever the time he entered, automatically went to non-billable side.
Yep.
Thanks, Ashish.
Kip.
Any questions, Stephen, you have to?
Nope.
Thank you.
Next is our tickets data. This is where Bali worked on 43 tickets and closed 24 of them. Rest of the tickets were either project tickets or maintenance tickets, which will go on for some more time on the basis of subtasks in those tickets. So they could not be closed within this time duration.
Yeah, unfortunately, some of the customers he works with, they take days to respond back and he can't connect to them until they respond and say, yes, go ahead. So it's not really on him. It's the, we have like 6 out of all of our customers that just like to wait days before saying 2 words.
So he's fine. We know it. We know the customers.
Yep.
Thank you, Steve.
Okay, way forward. So we have a board review that remains A priority. I will continue to do so.
That's something there.
This is our AI by design, so Sarah already covered this during the build IT presentation, so I can skip this one already.
And that's it.
The.
Easy.
Yep, fast and quick. Any other questions, Dipon, you have for us?
Nope, I'll plan to look at the.
build page and see if it's something that we are interested in and we'll just keep.
Working with Arnie and...
Yep.
I don't expect any changes, but I'll let you know if anything pops up.
Sure, that would be wonderful. And Stephen, as you mentioned, like Ben is most of the time he's in Vegas or traveling to other places. I'll definitely recommend that once I should be sharing the minutes of meeting, I'll send you a separate presentation along with the link so that you can share it along with Ben. Or probably I'll keep
Sure.
Mhm.
Yeah.
when in loop so that he will have a visibility that will be beneficial for you in terms of networking with other MSP partners.
Bhattacharjee.
Sure.
Perfect. It was a pleasure meeting with you, Stephen. Rest to take care of yourself. Wishing you a speedy recovery once again, and we'll be in touch.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Dipon. Have a good one.
Hey, you too. Bye.
Take care. Bye.
Bye.